Transcriber: İrem Gülderen
Gözden geçirme: Yiğit Yıldırım
Herkese merhaba.
Ben Diyetisyen Güneş Aksöz.
Sevgili arkadaşlar, bugüne kadar çok
fazla kariyer konuşmasına katıldım.
Gittiğim yerlerde hep kendi
hikayemi anlattım.
Nasıl bir yol izledim, nereden başladım,
nereye gittim...
Fakat bugün sizlere bu yolu
anlatmayacağım, bambaşka bir mesaj
vereceğim ama aslında başka gibi gözüken
işin özünü sizlerle paylaşmak istiyorum
bugünkü konuşmamda. Şimdi, konuşmamın
başlığına da bakarsanız zaten çok net
anlayacaksınız.
Aslında ben sizlere günün anlam
ve önemiyle ilgili çok net bir mesaj
vermek istiyorum.
Bu mesajın ana başlığı da
“Sen kendine bak”.
Sen kendine bak derken ne demek istiyorum?
Çok minik şöyle bir giriş
yapmak gerekirse:
Çocukken
hepiniz hayaller kurdunuz, ben
de öyle, eminim kurdunuz.
Yani bunların bazıları uçuk
kaçık hayallerdi, bazıları çok
daha gerçekçi idi.
Bazıları ailenizin belki sizi
yönlendirdiği hayallerdi.
“Sen şöyle mi yapsan, sen böyle
mi yapsan” dediler belki.
Belki de tamamen çocukça
kurduğumuz hayallerdi. İmkansız
gibi gözüküyordu.
Ama aslında burada size söylemek istediğim
çok önemli bir sır var.
Sır diyorum.
Hala bazı insanlar için sır, bazı insanlar
için de hayatın gerçekleri ve
başarıya gitme yolu.
Çocukken kurduğunuz hayallerin
hepsinin
ya da birçoğunun gerçek
olduğunu düşünün,
düşünebiliyor musunuz
şu anda? Ne istiyorsanız, ne yapmayı
düşünüyorsanız, ne kadar o anda size
saçma da gelse ya da “Yok ya ben öyle şey
istiyorum ama yok canım, nasıl yapayım?”
dediyseniz, bütün bunların
gerçek olduğunu düşünün.
Olabilir mi? Olabilir.
O yüzden “Sen kendine bak” diyorum.
Çünkü hayatınız boyunca hep insanlar
sizin hayatınızı bir şekle
sokmaya çalışacak.
Bir düşünün, aileniz, öğretmenleriniz,
arkadaşlarınız, hepsi size
fikirler verecek.
Siz bir şey söylediğinizde mutlaka
onun nasıl olmayacağını size
belki anlatacaklar.
Evet aralarında olacak,
“Sen yaparsın, ben sana güveniyorum”
diyenler de çıkacak,
eğer şanslıysanız.
Ama genelde böyle olmuyor. Genelde
insanlar bunun ne kadar büyük
bir hayal olduğunu,
“Yok ya, sen bu hayalleri bırak da
hayatın gerçekleriyle yüzleş .
Sen artık kendine gel, toparla kendini.”
İnsanların
genelde tepkileri böyle olur.
Aslında ben niye bunu söylüyorum?
Tabii ki ben de böyle yaşadım.
Ben de çocukken bazı hayaller kurdum ve
o hayallerin peşinden etrafımdaki tüm
olumsuz hikayelere rağmen, “Sen artık
büyüdün” ya da “Artık büyü” diyenlere
rağmen, “Bırak şu çocukça hayalleri,
canım sen de bir türlü vazgeçmiyorsun”
diyenlere rağmen
asla vazgeçmedim.
Hayatımla ilgili bugün başardığım herhangi
bir şey varsa bütün bunları, size
çok net söylüyorum ki, çocukken
kurduğum hayallere borçluyum.
Bu hayal bir oyunun içinde olabilir.
Birkaç satır da olabilir, söylediğiniz
bir şarkı da olabilir.
Bu hayal arkadaşınızla paylaştığınız
bir şey de olabilir.
Yani hayatınızla ilgili ne yapmak
istediğinize dair ipuçları,
siz bunları çocukken
vermeye başlıyorsunuz.
Kendinize vermeye başlıyorsunuz.
Hiç kimseyle ilgisi yok aslında bunların.
Yani “Onun yüzünden olamadı,
bunun yüzünden olamadı“,
evet, ben de bu cümleleri kurdum ama
bunların çok faydası olmadı.
Neyin faydası oldu?
Kendime bakmanın faydası oldu.
Ben kendime bakmaktan bu
konuda vazgeçmedim.
Kendine bak derken ne demek istediğimi
çok iyi anladınız.
Hayalleriniz, ne istediniz?
Kendinizi nerede gördünüz?
Ne yapmak istiyorsunuz?
Ben insanlara yardım etmek istedim
her zaman, onların sorunlarını
çözmek istedim.
Daha mutlu yaşasınlar istedim.
Aslında hayatı güzelleştirmek istedim.
Daha çok paylaşmak istedim,
öğrendiğim bir şey anlatmak istedim. Ama
çocukken bunu belki de şöyle söylüyordum:
“Ben bir yazar olacağım, kesin,
benim kitaplarım olacak.”
Bu hayallerden sadece bir tanesiydi.
Benim bugün altı tane kitabım var,
iki tanesi yolda.
Bugün yarın çıkacak birkaç
tane daha geliyor.
Ben şimdi faydalı kitapları olan bir yazar
olmak istiyorum. Ben aslında diyetisyenim,
zaten insanların hayatını güzelleştirmek
için çabalıyorum.
Ama hayatımda hayal ettiğim, uçuk kaçık
bulunan, aklınıza ne geliyorsa, birçok şey
deneyimledim, yaşadım.
Çok iyi geldi, ama kendi çabamla,
kendi içimdeki o rüyaya ve o hayallere
inanmaya devam ettiğim için bu
yolda onları bulabildim.
Bakın hiçbiri karşıma tesadüfen çıkmadı.
Hiçbiri, bir şey hariç, çok şanslı
olduğum için çıkmadı.
Bence şans tek başına yeterli değil.
Siz ne istediniz?
İçinizde ne vardı ?
Neyi hayal ediyorsunuz?
Neyi hayal ediyorsanız sizin yanınızda
onunla alakalı şeyler karşınıza çıkıyor.
Çok zor sınavlar var.
Evet, hayatın içinde bir sürü testler var
ve bu sınav ve testler aslında sizin
o yoldan vazgeçip vazgeçmeyeceğinizi
sınıyorlar. “Dur
bakalım ne olacak?” diye.
Vazgeçmeyip devam edenler var,
etrafınızda vardır.
Ben onlardan biriyim.
Ve inadına hayallerinden vazgeçmeyen,
“Ne olursa olsun ben içimdekine, hayal
ettiğime ulaşmak istiyorum” diyen.
Birebir aynısı olmayabilir.
Belki hayal ettiğinizden daha farklı,
daha iyi bir şey
çıkabilir. Biraz yolda gördüklerine izin
veren, fırsatları gören, görmek için çaba
harcayan, odaklanan insanlar vardır.
Ve onlar ne yaparlar biliyor musunuz?
Onlar yolda çok yorulurlar.
Evet, şikayet de edebilirler ama
vazgeçmezler, geri dönmezler.
“Tamam buraya kadarmış” demezler.
Yürümeye devam ederler.
Bir de bazı insanlar vardır, belki
çok iyi bir yolda yürüyorlardır.
Belki size göre “İşte ya, tam istediğim
gibi” dediğiniz şeyler yaşıyorlardır.
Ama görmezler.
Çünkü onların içlerinde belki
başka şeyler vardır. Belki
farklı bir şey bekliyorlardır.
O yüzden, yapmanız gereken, eğer başarılı
olmak ve mutlu olmak istiyorsanız, sadece
başarılı olmak mutlu etmez, sadece
mutlu olmak da başarıyı getirmez.
Başarmak, mutlu olmak istiyorsanız, “Ben
hayal kuruyorum ama ne yapacağımı
bilmiyorum” diyorsanız
yürümeye devam edin.
Ne istiyorsanız sürekli kendinize bakın.
Etrafınıza, size söylenen tüm olumsuz
cümlelere gözünüzü ve kulağınızı kapatın.
Duyun, eleştirileri de duyun, insanların
ne kadar inanmadıklarını da görün.
Çünkü bu sizi gaza getirecek.
Bu size yardım edecek.
Bu size destek olacak.
Kızacaksınız ama vazgeçmeyeceksiniz.
Yürümeye devam ettiğinizde
hatalar yapacaksınız.
Çok zorlandığınız anlar olacak ve
zorlandığınız anlarda aklınıza getirmeniz
gereken tek bir cümle var.
“Şu anda öğreniyorum.”
Emin olun çok zorlandığınız bir şeyde, bir
anda, bir konuda güzel bir
ders alıyorsunuz demektir.
Özel ders gibi düşünün. Size
özel hazırlanmış , sadece sizin
öğrenebileceğiniz şekilde.
Eğer o dersi alırsanız yolda yürümeye
devam edersiniz ve amacınıza ulaşırsınız.
Kendinizi görmek istediğiniz yer ne ise
içinizde, oraya doğru yürürsünüz.
Ama şikayet ederseniz, görmek
istemezseniz, vazgeçersiniz.
Bu da bir seçim.
O da sizsiniz.
Pişman olabilirsiniz.
O da bir duygu.
O da belki başka bir kapıya
sizi götürecek.
Ama bu konuşmanın özeti şudur:
Benim gördüğüm ve yolda yürüdüğüm
yolculukta başarıya giden ve bizi mutlu
eden, galiba iyi gidiyorum dedirten,
çünkü bu yolun sonu yok.
Yapmak istediğim çok fazla şey var.
Hayallerim daha bitmedi.
Sizinkiler de bitmesin.
Çocukken ne istediğinizi hatırlayın
ve onu yazın bir yere.
Ve sonra dönüp kendinize
bakın: “Şu anda onun
neresindeyim?“. Oradan çok uzaklaşmadan,
onun etrafında gezerek yola devam
ediyorsanız eğer, iyi bir yolculuktasınız
demektir. Yolda başınıza
gelenlerden şikayet etmek
hiçbir zaman işe yaramaz.
Sadece yolda başınıza gelen her iyi şeyden
ve her kötü şeyden haberdar olun,
farkında olun, ama nereye
gittiğinizi bilin. Ne
istediğinizi bilin.
O zaman zaten sizi mutlu eden güzel
bir kapıya ulaşacaksınız.
Eminim ki başaracaksınız.
Vazgeçmeyen insanlar hayatlarında mutlaka
çok fazla şey kazanıyorlar.
Belki beklemedikleri şeyler de
öğreniyorlar, kazanıyorlar ama emin olun
tecrübe çok önemli bir şey.
Bir de nereden baktığınız çok önemli.
“Ben bu tecrübeyi aldım, cebime koydum ve
şimdi daha güçlü bir şekilde yoluma devam
ediyorum” derseniz eğer, o güçle
beraber büyürsünüz.
Ama işte “Ben tecrübeyi aldım.
Tamam, anladım ki bu iş olmayacak”
derseniz aynı yerde kalırsınız ve
mutsuz olabilirsiniz.
Umarım güzel bir mesaj verebilmişimdir.
İşin özetini sadece anlatmak istedim,
paylaşmak istedim.
Çünkü ben gerçekten o çocukluk
hayallerinin çok işe yaradığını
düşünüyorum.
Farklı bir şekilde belki aktarıyoruz ama
aslında söylemek istediğimiz şey aynı,
gitmek istediğimiz yolculuk aynı.
Hepimiz an o anda eğlenmek ve tadını
çıkarmak, ve istediğimiz gibi olsun
istiyoruz. Olmuyorsa da başka bir yol
bulmamız gerekiyor.
Ama umarım bu yolculukta istediğiniz varış
noktasına ulaşırsınız. Ama varış
noktasının sonu yok,
bunu da söyleyeyim.
Her zaman bir sonraki, bir sonraki, bir
sonraki yerleri de görmek isteyeceksiniz.
Ve umarım başarıyla, mutlulukla
geçen; harika, eşsiz, size özel bir
yolculuğunuz olur.
Umarım bu videonun da size faydası olur.
Buradan da olsa tanıştığıma çok
memnun oldum, çok sevgiler.